welcome to this video and it's an
English Defence maybe yeah e 6 b 6
against now I Queens Queen pawn opening
start with C forward he played deform
quite quickly yeah Bishop to g5 now
Knight f6 leads to a quince onion of
course I'm not term not a big problem
wasn't at the position i intended to
play with it's certainly not bad okay
let's play in the most straightforward
manner then f5
yeah Black has got a really nice knight
on e4 and if you get some extra moves
here for black like Knight to d7 92f six
or something or queen e7 Queen f6 and g6
some more builder moves that support the
not only for then black get some in an
excellent shape what white needs to do
is supply d5 and exactly i think in this
position not sure if you have the time
to to wait any longer d5 film is I think
answered by Knights of a 6 or 9 27 I
think night a success them I have okay
so he spends one more move ok I think 97
cannot be wrong really mm-hmm okay so
just let's just take it so what is why
it's idea f3 and you form may be okay I
don't want to play Knight f6 because of
c-5 this looks like something I want to
want to prevent h5 h4 I am it's a
possibility age 5
very very crude but come on it seems to
get something going on the on the King
side the only issue of course is my king
I need to really be sure that I get the
kingdom off to the to the Queen side and
now I was intending maybe hmm how r g4 I
don't have anything developed right now
I need to play a queen f6 and long
hassle or develop this is the wrong way
but opening up further here um can be
can be fatal really okay so I don't want
to really play F for this looks like the
position would close up further let's
let's castle I'd rather play g4 yeah g4
know could be my next move okay he
doesn't really react to this okay a5 is
something he can he can play for of
course okay I need to get something
going here he takes on g4 chick with
rook one time with Sergey foul and the
the bishop on b7 gets into play again I
didn't really wanted to spend the move
on a five I think he needs to to react
in some way I don't think he can play a
five I think I would take yeah ok so
let's look just grab with rook and this
shouldn't be too bad
I have the g file open already and if he
takes on f5 does g2 hanging ok he
ignores it let's double on the gphone
cannot be bad ok so I'm if I would cook
a I can be sure before I could consider
this but the long diagonal it's nothing
to be a bit cautious about that ok yeah
how how to improve improve on on the
disposition if I play what about e5 rook
takes f5 to have Queen takes f5 takes on
f5 rook takes g2 yeah it's probably not
not enough really how to improve this
position Knight to f6 here would be
helpful maybe he m and then Knight f6
coming cannot take on f5 energy to a
saying I hope
not overlooking some something-something
on the queenside iam but I don't don't
really see it doesn't have any attacking
pieces um so shouldn't be a any threat I
wonder if he maybe maybe he can take on
f5 Bishop takes g2 looks like complete
disaster yeah of course this is a always
always a possibility so 95 or takes only
for I don't know come on let's play
quickly 95 this looks good someone
Knight f3 yeah it's also threat didn't
really appreciate that but this is a big
threat neither 3m rook f3 rubgy to end
and over needs to react somehow don't
know how don't see move Knight f3 okay
can move for I don't know 93 now too
yeah come on this must be enough really
King f1 rook g1 and strongly yeah okay
meds it's it's winning i can i can just
take the Queen I mean let's say here and
I just I just grabbed it him Quincy to a
threat he doesn't have anything to to
counter this doesn't look like oh he's
got any any counter counter threats yeah
thanks for watching so look look quite
nice I think I'm 11 point I'm really in
this position i'm pretty sure that you
need to go at d5 it's at least them at
least the main the main move here d5 you
need to undermine this this night and I
think the usual responses something like
this yeah so this works nicely and if
you take here and you play Queen to f6
yeah and c3 is hanging with check and um
white can can do something like this but
this leads to a position where white
pawns are simply terrible and black will
gain regain them and pawn easily and
tell forum and okay position it's not
it's not clear I think maybe it's a
slightly better for what or something
but it's a playable line from both sides
yeah thanks for watching this